all right Anthony
oh where you where'd you grow up where
are you from originally well I was born
in Portsmouth Virginia
p-o-r-t-s-m-o-u-t-h Virginia uh which is
in the Tidewater area
uh where they changed it now to Hampton
Roads but I was raised in the city of
Norfolk in our 4lk
and um I was um I didn't know what a
town because of course I was an infant
um but uh my biological mother found out
she couldn't take care of me it had a
means to support me so she put me up for
adoption and the doctor that she had for
her primary uh position it was was the
same position for uh just wonderful and
beautiful Japanese woman named ayako and
a wonderful loving uh African-American
man named Charles Henry Taylor
um they end up becoming my parents and
uh
I wouldn't have known if he would have
told me when I was about six years old I
don't remember but I asked him when I
was uh grown how did I know I was
adopted all my life and I didn't know
how I knew he told me that he explained
to to me that he uh that he and my
mother loved loved me to you know with
all this heart soul in mind and that we
are his parents but uh yeah I have
biological parents a Filipino father and
a Hawaiian mother at least that's what
they were told a very unique accent for
a for us Asian Asian yeah yeah yes um
yeah I was raised in a all when I mean
oh I mean 100 that means the
neighborhood the the school the the
crosswalk letter the candidate everyone
was African-American uh myself and my
mother were the only two uh in this
large community that was um not
African-American so your childhood was
good with your adopted parents actually
it was fantastic as as it was fantastic
as my parents but uh I began to get in
trouble my own self um uh you know
making my own decisions at a young age
and and most of them weren't too good
what were you like in high school
um actually I got in trouble quite often
but I loved high school because I was
very popular and
um the school work wasn't too hard for
me I loved the girls to see the girls
every day but were I stayed in trouble
often and it seems that um it's
following me of course I know that's not
the case now
um it's by my own means that I got in
trouble why do you think you were
attracted to things that got you in
trouble well I wanted to fit in and I I
guess I did with the um I guess the guys
you would call bad guys uh they were
popular also and it seems that the girls
like them more and and they had fun and
I wanted to have all those things too
you graduated high school no but I I
want to tell everyone I did because I
was through this morning school
um actually it was a it was a
it was very dramatic ending to my high
school
um days uh I did get expelled which
means meant I couldn't go to no more
public schools for
um it was basically just getting in too
much trouble small trouble fights and
um disrespecting teachers and nothing
real big and nothing that was criminal
but um it was bad enough with my
reputation that um they the the
principal actually stood up in front of
me and he actually shared it to you and
he said he said
you know
it's not too late you know you can still
do do good do the right thing and
get your GD or some type of security
what grade was this this was
I believe it was the 10th grade because
I'm I was 17. I wasn't sure which grade
I belonged yeah I should have been in
the level or even maybe the 12. what
what uh what did you do with your life
after getting kicked out of high school
well I did go to uh The Learning Center
and uh it was five minutes late before
the test and that was a big deal because
I didn't get a second chance so maybe 30
years later yeah
and so I'm with nothing to do and all
this energy being young and vibrant and
and I like to thank the girls like me
too and I wanted to show off I guess and
and still wanted to fit in
um I started to get in trouble and
things started to be even criminal from
like I'm breaking in
small stuff really though breaking the
schools and and doing things that's
that's illegal that you spent some time
in jail yes I did prison too
um yes I did I went to um the Detention
Center as a juvenile
and my dear Mother
um she's a mother mother she's not she's
not we're the queen with the criminal
law and stuff like that so
um it hurt her to the core of her so she
she would cry and I would hate myself
for it
um she would put her hands in her in her
face and cry like a little girl you know
yeah I I couldn't stand it but she's
still I still
um John intro
and how old are you now
57 57 yes
and you're living on Skid Row
right this moment yes I'm in the
apartment yes I live in a so I'm
assuming drugs are part of your life
oh
at one time it wasn't and
um I was crying for
eight and a half years
through
Narcotics Anonymous um and going to a
program
um there's a lot of ways to get clean
but this was a proven way and
um I still believe that um like you know
get clean almost again what are your
drugs and
opiates
so uh crack
yes and uh heroin or fentanyl yes yeah
that's a popular combination down here
yes
you know it's hard to even admit that
but
yeah that's true
and you um
you do what for money
oh well I actually work I don't want to
do anything that I would say I would
cross the line right now you know right
now I'm not doing other criminal
activities or uh and these I don't think
so no no I don't
um I actually careful uh uh someone that
um actually allows me to earn enough
money to support myself and um a little
bit of the habit
but uh
what job is that that you provider for a
recipient
true provider for uh like a caregiver oh
I see okay for one person
and growing up the way
you know in a neighborhood that you grew
up in with an African-American father
and you're at your unique accent tell me
how that's affected your life
differently than a typical Asian young
man well of course I didn't look like
anyone that's the number one thing I
didn't know that the exact moment when I
realized that I didn't look like anyone
but when I I did know that
um I didn't look like uh everyone else
it was somewhere around kindergarten and
I know that everyone was
African-American we used to sing the old
negro spirituals and and I was right
there with them and I learned how to
sing our souls with soul and I was
raised I felt like I was raised oh yeah
I raise the black man
um that um not um something that you
would say um it was an act or something
if you was raised in like Tarzan by the
Apes I mean you know whatever right you
you're gonna adopt two now
um this is a real me right here um I
actually uh I didn't like the way I
looked uh because I felt like people
were looking at me all the time man you
know what sometimes they were especially
on somewhere that I'm not well known
everyone's uh would would um yeah
Naturals which is uh African-American
hair and and um darker skin and yeah I
wanted to have all that you wanted to
fit in yeah without having to do things
and you know commit to doing things um
to do it you know I wanted to just look
like I want you know but um I had a
wonderful job that I would say uh you
know I don't think this is a bad thing
to say my grandmother
um some people call it bootlegging but
no she didn't make any wrong time she's
so uh alcohol and vodka
um and champion
and she just did it for the mainly for
the company she wouldn't get rich or
nothing but she would have all this
confidence in every odor and
African-American and this was a
these were the fun drunks they would
laugh and joke and have a good time all
the time and so coming up and I'm the
little Asian guy and um they knew
Mildred which is my little grandmother
they knew I was number one in her life
so everybody treated me
special and I loved it man it's a very
unique I'm bringing you had because
being an Asian young man you could have
had a very straight laced conservative
you know knows in the you know yes the
grindstone studying Straight A's
upbringing but you ended up right
getting an African-American upbringing
which is more Freewheel and more fun
perhaps more focused on uh enjoyment
right exactly I'm glad you you put it
that way uh
um I don't blame
um my situation going up in a
African-American Community uh for me to
get in trouble not not at all because I
need my own decisions in my dad and my
mother was great Educators you know for
for me and I was nurturing I was loved
your dad was a good guy a great guy
wonderful one of the best
men
regardless of color
you know that I've known and he didn't
never introduce me as his stepson or
anything nothing but his son and I think
it was great too
yeah the world needs more of that right
direction in your life tell me about you
have children
I have one daughter you have one
daughter and two grandkids you were
married no I never got married I feel a
man in love with my high school
this is an African-American woman yes
she is yeah beautiful as a matter of
fact
uh all dudes make all the women were uh
I've known I've never met a woman to
this day that were it was more beautiful
I really mean that because she was my
woman but I really
I was captivated
are you open to other
races yes of course man I never had a
um see I try to try not to see colors
I don't even you know if they're purple
or green no don't even come come from my
lips uh if I'm attracted to a
particularly one of the businesses of uh
opportunity yeah it'd be great it's a
it's all about the compatibility you
know I mean
um
I've had all African-American
girlfriends up until I guess I was an
adult and you know then
um and the reason mostly because of that
was
um it was preference I guess too but
also
um was available for myself to the
community
but when they're older I guess you can
grant y'all more and do other things and
and of course
um meet new people right when you when
you ended up with somebody other than a
black girl what what did you end up with
she was good Lord she was white white
girl yes how did she compare to your I
can't even compare
um it was born she was kind of
like me
but you know she didn't
um try to act a certain way her hair
come all the way down to her thighs I
mean no to
um uh gas yeah and um
she she was a happy wonderful person so
it didn't even um
it does no good to stereotype all right
that's right
so you have how many children I have two
well not one daughter and two
grandchildren oh I see and you raised
your daughter
no I wanted to uh I still got in trouble
um be honest um I didn't know her mother
very well
um it seems like it was always meant to
be I guess it was because it happened
right it was meant to be right so
um yeah um yeah I didn't know it very
well and
um
I wasn't incarcerated when my daughter
was born so I lost church and I wanted
to see her because all we wanted a
daughter I was and I and I had the name
for ever since third grade believe it or
not it was a girl named Tiffany and so I
thought she was so pretty and I don't
know how I thought about these things
that it is but I did I remember there's
your daughter named Tiffany yes and his
middle name is the second name that I
wanted which was in the seventh grade
and my last period class it was a a
young beautiful girl named Nicole
what would you say is your biggest
regret in your life oh my goodness
if I couldn't I can't put it into a
nutshell but drugs is definitely at the
top
um
drugs and
um making bad decisions
knowing that they bad decisions did you
feel like the
tendency urge whatever whatever you want
to call it to make bad decisions comes
from something genetic from your
biological wow
um actually hey I said I didn't expect
you guys like but yes no question about
it because your parents were straight
laced yeah but they're my adopted turns
I know but the ones that raised you were
not into drugs right they weren't maybe
a little alcohol but that's it I'm a
dead drink but he didn't drink too
enough never saw him drunk if he was I
couldn't tell
yeah
but you picked up that
tendency right maybe it's something you
inherited yeah exactly I believe so I
met my mother's side and my father's
side
biological parents and you never met
your yes I did you meet your biological
parents yes I came to California for
that reason oh is that right this is a
great story yeah let's hear that
um actually I was 24 years old and my
mother I knew her name ever since I was
14 because I found a letter
um and
it was it was taped
um to my adopted mother
um she wanted me back she was gonna
fight for me when I was young she never
showed up to court so but I didn't know
her name was Blaze and it was Place
Salon wet at the time
and um It's a Long Way sound didn't
sound like a Hawaiian like I didn't look
at it too much anyway
um fast forward I was 24 years old uh I
was contacted by a woman asked me did I
know a woman named Blaze I said yes this
is my mother right yes you want to speak
to her of course I do I've never had no
no animosity I didn't want to meet my
mother the woman that gave birth to me
so uh it was exciting so
um we uh I finally got the number and
recall and the first time I heard a
voice it was an answering machine and it
was a deep voice I thought and uh when
it was funny well I finally got in
contact with her and to make long story
well I'm not it's not going to be short
but it'll be shorter she um CA I asked
me don't want to come out here to visit
us of course I do all right so I did I
came
um on the bus believe it or not I never
do that again almost 3 000 miles
um
from Norfolk Virginia to San Francisco
but uh yeah she lived in Santa Clara
which is on our skirts and Silicon
Valley she um took five days uh because
I found out you can get off the bus and
let your lugs go ahead and you can stop
and play so I stopped in Chicago Omaha
Nebraska
um I did make it there and I I was kind
of matured because I thought at the
whole California was warm and wonderful
all year round this was in March and it
was up North so it was about 40 some
degrees and you can see your breath and
everything I was like wow I had one big
old ugly piece of luggage and it took me
about two hours to find her apartment
because I got there a little later than
she thought uh and we didn't meet at the
bus station so I found her apartment at
about 11 30 at night it was even colder
in the 30s and I walked up to the door
and uh and all these big emotions
because I'm
um I was excited happy uh even even said
in in May all the same time but
um overall was um excited so
um another law seemed like she took
forever when she answered the door she
turned and um and it slowed it open and
when I looked up at her I looked down at
her looked straight at her I was
flabbergasted I mean I was shocked to
the core matter of fact I thought it was
the wrong uh residence
the woman stood before me
was just spitting in this and I mean
spitting him is a blue silver I'm
talking about the Lucille Ball
um she could pass for Lucifer she had
the red hair and everything petite small
woman this is her biological well
dressed yeah well dressed
um so I'm thinking Hawaiian okay
um and guess what this is even more kind
of
um interesting I think
um we just stood there without one word
no one said hi no one said anything we
just looked at each other and it was
awkward it was tense and
I didn't know what what to do but I mean
it just was her
uh you know I brought it down and I just
I just felt a lot of things we didn't
know what to say finally after about
believe it in about four minutes that's
a long time she said some glasses on she
put him over nose and said in a Stern
Voice come in sit down I'm like oh my
goodness is it just disabled uh is it
gonna be like this so I'm going to come
in and she had a nice cozy well kept you
know nice apartment uh neat so I go sit
on the cross like she all told me to and
everything seemed to go in slow motion
then uh I looked better she closed the
door turned around and she seemed to
saunter over to the city
in my lap
I pick up the paper and I look at the
top left corner and I see that it's her
name Blaze Blas that's your nickname
never met anyone with that name and then
I Saw Martinez
say Martini is hold on now it was long
way
um and then
then this Martinez I don't know so I
started to read the rest of the paper
now
I see that is her birth certificate hers
her birthday
and after 24 years 11 months in one week
I remember that too because it was that
important to me I discovered I'm Eternal
allow all my life now and it's because
all my friends were told that and he
related to me she was born in Hawaii
but she's a full-blooded Puerto Rico and
I said I'm Puerto Rican she said where I
am I guess you are too and she was
pretty dramatic also and I'm like wow I
wasn't mad I was just
it was shocking to me actually now Not
only was it a different uh it was a
whole different ethnicity right Spanish
right I'm like wow okay I'm glad I was
raised by good friends and I didn't hate
Puerto Rico
um anyway so was your father
um well let me get to that I tell you
about that he's Filipino but
um I actually
uh okay I had it was kind of awkward
like I said and you know you can imagine
my biggest question
um and if you don't know what it means
yeah that's good right then why you give
me away what happened
it was too early for me I didn't want to
ask him right now I think it was a
little too soon
um
so I had another question did I really
was excited about
I said look all my life I've been the
only child
uh do I have any siblings do I have any
brothers and sisters
and so this is what she did exactly she
took off her glasses sat down across the
lids and she said it's something like
this okay I didn't marry your daddy your
daddy a Philippine woman in Burbank
California she said now you got three
sisters
Cassandra is eight years older than you
her dad is black and she looks black
Rebecca is one year younger you she has
the same fathers you do so she looks
Asian just like you now Jennifer
is
birthday as a Canadian she looks snowy
white like me and
I kind of stuck with her
um you know I thought it broke a lot of
ice and okay so I thought maybe okay
moment around the block so what I love
it I love it it's all great uh I had no
problem with that at all I know I got
three sisters and I always wanted a
little sister oh they're half sisters
two on and one night two the middle one
we have the same father same time yeah
yeah
you're quite a mix yes yeah I think so
yeah yeah biologically in your culture
oh yeah you grew up in uh uh the whole
the whole mix everything the uh yeah I
think it's critics um interesting at
least so why did your mom give you up
okay so uh my father was in the Navy
um they got together
um this this is this is my mother and
um they knew each other she worked at a
bar and they began dating and um and she
he had to go out to sea and when he went
on to see she's on her she was pregnant
with me and so she wrote him and she
wrote him and she wrote them and never I
was a lot of return
um by my father so uh she she wrote my
aunt and tried to get help from her and
I guess that that didn't come out too
great either so
um my uncle her brother Melvin
um a time he told I talked to him before
just after I met her and stuff and he
told me that um
she didn't want
um wanted you know that she she even had
a son
you know she had one or son with from my
grandmother and but he told him and when
she said he's gonna put me up for
adoption my uncle was like no no you
can't do that send it to me so she did
he was in New Jersey and
I believe his wife had I'm not sure why
terrorists soon after and she couldn't
take care of me so he sent me back and
then she put me on for adoption and
that's how it was told by my mother
interesting yeah
your life is quite an interesting story
it is this
and you're happy here in this life that
you're living in now
you know what I think
Los Angeles is the best place in the
world
and when things are great
it's yeah and things are not anywhere
yeah
um can be one of the worst uh it's about
your daily life right
um right now it's not so good
yeah and that's another story really but
um
I'm always
um I always was a Believer at least I
shared that
Facebook
is very excited everything
and I like to still believe that
for right now
well yeah I still believe it the bright
side would be now
because I even when they say deaf right
what's the bright side of that right
well I'm a firm believer
I might get in trouble with a lot of
people
I'm probably believing that um
when they see you going to a better
place I believe I believe that to be
true when it's a better place
you know I mean
heaven for me is resting in peace
and to me
not have to worry about a thing or have
any uh uh um pain or something or
anything it is blessing in peace and to
me if you really think deep about it
um
it would be wonderful
and having to live forever would be
terrible I would say because I couldn't
even Escape that
if I had to live forever
and I was raised to believe that if I
did the right thing and
I'm gonna go deep deep into that but you
can imagine I was raising the church I
was raised going to are you a religious
person no no no you're not I used to
well I was one time yeah back back to
how you were raised I mean so your your
tastes
for like music and things like that is
is it reflects the community you grew up
in no question about it I love r b
um I sing I sing too
um I'm not a professor thing but I
believe I could uh I've been in a few
musicals and
um I like to sing
um and my favorite
um on genres love ballads sad songs sad
love songs because they
um
they are very moving which artists do
you particularly oh wow is okay uh
Luther Vandross now uh Patti LaBelle
woman uh
um Atlanta Star group in um
um
but also like Journey also you know
white groups Eagles what not uh
definitely in the community grew up and
affected your taste yes yes yes but I I
reached down
um I'm gonna get a little older to find
out hey man it's more mature than um
can you know just remember the time not
a little space in the Park Place to name
my neighborhood yeah there's more to it
so
all right what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life wow did I learn it though that's
the thing
what do you think the most important
lesson you need to learn okay uh
two
to do was
was good and right
and believe what I used to to
um say I believe it was to to
see everybody said everything
um
I mean good solid decisions and ask
questions of everything
um critical thinking
is you know even the things I know I
know I know
[Music]
yeah be a good person just because
all right
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you so much
thanks thank you very much